[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael
welcome to the edition of ask Evan today
I'm going to answer a question from one
of our forum readers wrote in asking
about fundraising so the question is how
everyone I'm looking for fundraising
ideas for nonprofits I know I can learn
a lot thanks for the question
to quickly answer it for you and I've
been on boards of nonprofit and charity
organizations in the past it can be
really tough you know everybody's asking
for donations and you have to separate
yourself from everybody else so I don't
know what what your nonprofit is doing
but you have to really find a way to
tell your story and a lot of the times
the people who are in charity work and
nonprofit are not great marketers and
they're not great at telling their
stories and the ones who raise the most
money are the ones who do a good job of
telling their story so I don't how much
money you're trying to raise or again
what it is that you do but you have to
create an emotional connection with
people who can potentially give you
money so what are you trying to raise
the money for and how can you tie that
home to a personal story of somebody and
draw me in and make me want to care
about this right we're bombarded all day
with tons of different messages and so
to make somebody stop and take 10
minutes out of their day to watch a
video or to go to your website and read
your story it's got to be compelling
right so don't just say what you do
explain how you do it and show the
people who you're helping so you know
smiling people how their testimonials
explain the importance of what it is
that you're doing so that's number one
for any marketing that you do for any
awareness if somebody's hitting your
website they see a brochure they see a
flyer it's got to have a strong
emotional immediate impact with the
person to make them care and want to at
least find out a little bit more about
what you're doing number one the second
thing is I try to get people involved in
the organization who have some
connection so when I was on the board of
Junior Achievement part of what we did
was raise funds through our own
connections so you're bringing up
people who can help not just with their
volunteer time but can also help raise
money either personally or through their
friends so often they'll have events if
it's a dinner or golf tournament or
something fun where you can try to get
corporate sponsors but also the people
who are involved try to line up their
own you know sponsors or their own
connections to be able to buy some of
the spots so you want to try to create a
board of advisers or Board of Directors
who can also not just give you advice
and can work hard and be volunteers but
can also provide you with financial
support and connections to financial
support so the most successful charities
and nonprofits again are the ones who
have a good board of advisers or
directors who are actively involved
committing their time but also
committing their dollars and getting
their friends involved as well so along
with telling your story and along with
getting the people involved the last
thing I would think of is really have a
clear vision for what you want to
accomplish so what is it that you're
trying to do and how does the world
gonna be better because of it right so
as much as possible you want to tie
people into that vision and get them
excited about the new world that you're
going to be able to create if they help
you with ABC right so there are that
many visions that are easy to get
excited about right and again people are
bombarded with messaging so if you give
them something that genuinely they can
get excited about and and you know be
really happy about then they are more
likely to get involved with you so what
is the world that you want to create and
it might be a massive vision I don't
know what the nonprofit again is about
it could be a local community vision
it's fine as long as you have a clear
vision for what you want to do number of
people help something you want to build
all the benefits attached to that the
more you have a clearly defined vision
that gets people excited the easier is
going to be they get people to come on
board and help them so hopefully those
ideas helped you if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up but makes
gonna do more for you and if you have a
question about this video you have a
comment
or question about your own business I'd
love to hear from you if you want to
leave it in the comment section below I
always read those I appreciate them and
I really like seeing them come in so
thank you and you'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]